I mean
doing cool
okay
folks I don't know why the lighting in
this room is always set to expensive
restaurant level which is you can't see
what you're eaing you can't see what
you're doing so the first thing I'm
going to try to do when I get in is I'm
going to turn the lights on Tough Enough
staying asleep when the lights are
on yeah he's so much perhaps a little
easier to stay away in the lights off
so I am writing my deep seek
post the G the story is starting right
so I'm going to try out what we have so
far and maybe you can help me so until
last Friday there was an AI story being
sold
right the AI story was a story of you
think in pieces of an AI architecture
that would require what until last
Friday what were we told really
expensive chips that Invidia had a
significant advantage over everybody
else and they were all scrambling but
you needed the chips and you also
needed huge amounts of data because the
argument is AI needs to go through the
data so it's a super Computing skills
Plus data which essentially already
creates a high entry cost for the
business right
and then what would the companies that
invest in the architecture do they
produce AI products and services that we
would all want so
much that we would pay premium prices
for why premium prices because only the
people who went through the entry
barrier would get
them the market buy into it I mean think
about the trillions in market cap that
have been added it's not just the
companies in the architecture space
right Invidia was obviously the most
logical one but it also was the power
companies the gas I mean there's a whole
ecosystem that built off these data
centers and on the product and service
side there was more skepticism why
because you could talk about AI products
and service we all I mean I don't know
what whatever program you use notice
it's a little AI button in them I have
no idea this's Zoom there's AI button on
Zoom I don't know what it does I'm
terrified to find out but every product
and service adds but let me ask you
question how many of you are paying a
premium for an AI addendum to your
product
you are okay that's good there's a start
here but that's a hope right the
products and services that's that that a
LinkedIn member will pay a premium to
buy LinkedIn
Ai and that Microsoft will be able to
charge a premium price because they and
only they spent that was until last
Friday I mean I know there are a lot of
distractions with the Deep seek
story person that came out of China and
already you get a political discussion
of what does this mean there was also a
distraction who cost only 6.3 million
which is an absolute lie we know that
that's
a it it might have been for a piece of
the puzzle my guess it cost hundreds of
millions we counted the time and know
maybe even a few Nvidia AI chips were
involved somewhere in the game to get it
off but it's an incredible
accomplishment even it cost them a
billion dollars that's less than what
what what is meta spending on AI
architecture this year I mean 65 billion
is the word and Microsoft of course you
know with 80 billion I mean a billions
and but what the bigger story here is
not whether deep seek is better than
chat
GPT it might or might not it's that it's
broken the story open by doing what by
saying a lot of these AI products and
services that will emerge don't
require those expensive chips don't
require data I've now early on one of my
problems the AI story is let's say I
build an AI model to do fair value
accounting it's a rule based system
entirely I don't need to dig through how
every accountant in history has ever
done accounting I couldn't care less in
fact it might be a distraction you give
me the
rules I don't need Super Chips it's not
rocket science add subtract multiply
divide I'm not running
simulations clearly for that business
you don't need that investment that's
it's like The Emperor's New Clothes
right why didn't I think about this
until last Friday
because we saw the people making the
pronouncements they came with degrees
with pedigree and they said these Tech
Titans and the VCS must know what
they're talking about and deep seek
basically said that might not be true y
you something like deep deep seat and
something like open AI in the same
Market classification Lo
ultimately they're not markets the
market is for products and services
neither open AI nor deep seek is a
product by itself by itself if this way
entire Market it's a tiny market right
so you're saying how much would people
pay for chat GPT as the end game if this
is your end market we've been paying way
too much for AI the truth is the AI
product and services a much they don't
specify but their claim is it can do
pretty much everything right it can
decide what what your next product
should be it can decide what geography
to go into so that's why I think this
whole discussion of deep seek better
than chat jpt there'll be like 12 12
articles you read over the next week
that try this out and say oh chat jpt
you know my wife uses chat GPT when you
know when she uses the most when she has
to send an email she teaches fifth grade
so you got to send an email to the
parent of a kid and she's really pissed
off she writes off the email in a pissed
off mood and then she asked chpt to
rewrite the email in more friendly terms
it does a really good job right because
it's read every email that's ever been
said in a and that's why deep seek
actually the first run of it shows that
it's better for scientific mechanical
rule based stuff than for writing a
better email to
parents so I think that that fight might
play out but ultimately this is about
what does it mean so let's go down down
the less what does it mean for the AR
architecture business post deep
sea will less money be spent on
architecture more money be spend in
architecture it has to be less money
right you don't need the big thing but
it doesn't mean that you don't invest in
vide chips not every a product and
service can do what what the deep sea
crowd and saying I don't have so there's
going to be a segment of that AI product
and service Market where the old story
still holds the question now is is that
40% of the market you're saying I don't
know this is the time to make your best
estimate you I'll wait for it to play
out you won't be buying an a stock till
2035 that by which time it's too
late what does it mean for the ultimate
product and services that come out of
air will there be will what deep seek to
increase that the number of products and
services we'll have access
to
absolutely but be commoditized a big
chunk of it is going to be commod
because entry is going to be so low so
from our from the consumer perspective
this is really good news you're going to
see a lot more AI stuff coming at you
and much of it will be either free or
really low cost so it basically made the
market both bigger and more
commoditized and if you're valuing a
company that's got to play out somewhere
in the middle where does a commoditize
play lower margin business big
business I think that it's going to play
out out and I'm going to take my first
shot at it and don't wait for my post
start thinking about how does this is
what valuation is thinking through
stories as they evolve so what I'd like
to do today is actually you know I'll
actually try to bring in Nvidia next
week so this week I want you to Value
the S&P 500 I put it out there I noticed
a few of you it's interesting because my
valuation of the S&P does anybody
remember what my valuation came out with
overvalued by
11.78% you know the median overvalue
there are 55 people I've checked in the
Google Shar spreadsheet the medians are
11.75% this is looking suspiciously like
you're tracking me but remember what I
said early in this process that's going
to happen later as we go through you're
going to disagree and that's going to be
healthy right so make it your story this
is this is my my my valuation is not the
valuation it's my
valuation make it yours so today I want
to start with the topic and this is
something you're going to see with every
class I'm going to start the class with
the start of the class quiz you know
what I'm going to quiz you on not what
we did last session but what we're going
to
do in the next you think this is stupid
that's ass backwards
right what I want to do with each of
these sessions at the start of the class
is in the test we're going I'm going to
show you the test and I'm going to ask
you to intuitively pick what you think
the answer is and 95% of the time you
know what you're going to find once we
go through all the gymnastics is your
intuition was right trust your gut and
hopefully this process will let start to
help you trust your God so one of the
things we're going to talk about today
is
bias what I mean by bias is when you sit
down to Value company the rest of you
comes along for the right what's the
rest of you your your brain your soul
your your your
history so let's say about first where
bias comes from bias essentially comes
from all over the place the first is
what I call the power of the
subconscious okay when you're valuing a
company to right this week when you
value viia my guess is your valuations
are going to get pushed down why because
you saw what happened in the market
you're a little nervous it's her
behavior you know it's it's you saying
that's not rational supremely rational I
feel sorry for the caveman who was a
contrarian he wouldn't have made it very
very long right the entire tribe is
running towards you run in the opposite
direction you're going to get stomped by
a mammoth or something along the way the
second is what I call hindsight bias
what is that well you look back and say
I knew deep seek was coming they're
going to be a incredibly large number of
people in CN BC claiming they saw the
whole
thing it's a complete lie but it's human
nature I saw that coming so some of this
you don't control it's it's it's kind of
of bubbling in the subconscious it's
going to find your way into your
valuation the second is the power of
suggestion now I once talked to a
managing director of of investment bank
and he was worried about the fact that
you know valuations were poor quality
and I said tell me how what you do he
was in the IPO section he said look we
have an IPO to Value I give my analyst
the Prospectors and ask them to Value
the company and I do throw a number at
the I think this company is's worth
about 8 times have it I think that's
where and he says they keep coming back
with an answer that confirms my initial
number I said what did you think would
happen you throw a number out there in
fact I remember
teaching a version of this class I think
what 15 years ago I taught two MBA
sections so completely random which
which person ended up in which section
and at that time there was a middle of
the semester project I used to include
which I don't anymore why because your
second year some of you prematurely
graduate so it's kind of tough to get
you to do stuff middle of the semester
but it's an
IPO same company for both groups I gave
them the Prospectors with one group I
get the prospect value the company try
your best the second group I said value
the company try your best and there are
rumors floating around that the offering
price might be about
$35 valuations come back the first group
the value sented around $21 second group
The valuation is M you know when you
when when I value IPL one of the things
I try to avoid looking at is that
offering price number starts to show up
in the news right the Wall Street it's
rumored
that the you saying I I can I can ignore
it you might be I I don't think I
can and third and this is the most
powerful force behind
bias is most of you will end up doing
valuation not for yourselves your
investment decisions but for a living
and I'm going to say something that
appraises find harsh harsh but the truth
shall set you free you tell me who pays
you and how much you get paid I'll tell
you which direction the bias
is and how much the bias
is I'll give you a story later on but I
want you to kind of think about buyers
because I'm now going to put you in a
position of somebody valuing a company
and what I want want you to tell me is
which direction the bias
is so let's say you're an
entrepreneur you have a business I'm a
venture capitalist so let's play Shark
Tank right I'm not Kevin Oria you can
pick any other shark you
want so you describe your business and
you want me to invest tell me how the VC
Capital raising structure works you come
and raise money from me what do I get in
return a not just Equity a piece of your
business
right so when you come in for this
negotiation and you're valuing your own
business for this negotiation do you
want to come in with a really high
number or a really low
number oh so where is it going to show
up you're going to Big growth rates and
if you use the VC game a high multiple
at the end a Target pricing basically
your bias is upward on the other side of
the table as a VC my bias Cuts in
exactly the other
direction much of the debate in venture
capital is not about value it's about
hey you know use a Target multiple of 10
I'll use one of four you discount that
back by 30% I'll use 50% what wec is
called discount rates it's a complete
lie it's just negotiating tool that 50%
is we know it's fiction but they can use
it to make your high number into a low
number
bias second let's say you're valuing
your business you now built a business
but you've gone through a very tough
personal Cor you're in the middle of a
divorce and you're soon to be exposed
who you don't like that much anymore is
demanding half the value of your
business so you come to me as an
appraisal to Value business do you want
a high number or a low number preferably
zero right because half of zero is zero
so you throw yourself at the mercy of
the Court say look I'm a terrible
business person I'm a horrible manager
I'll run my business into the ground is
what zero give my expose half of zero
let's say you're an appraiser for an
owner who is getting a value for the
company because a tax guy wants to take
30% of that number I think there might
be a wee bit of bias in what you
do yeah you want the number to be as low
as possible if you look at private
company appraisal 80% of valuations of a
divorce court Tax Court where the
objective is to get the number as lowest
possible you know how this shows up
there's a heck of a lot of discounting
that happens in private company
valuation
they'll value a company and take off 25%
for a liquidity why make the number
lower they can't say that but know it's
full liquidity then they'll take another
30% off you're a private company now
you're getting desperate you can't even
name the discount I'm surprised after
all this discounting you end up with the
number greater than zero but I can see
the buers playing
on and if you're in Appraiser for the
IRS you have the exact opposite
objective the only thing is the IRS is
usually cheap it doesn't pay its expert
witnesses that much so when this gets
into a contest and you know they tend to
lose but it's still two sides pulling in
different
directions
and let's say you are an equity research
analyst for those of you not familiar
with how equity research is structured
you buy side equity research analyst who
do they work
for Fidelity State Street they work for
mutual fund or fund management companies
their job is to Value companies so they
Prof their portfolio mates
internally can pick stocks decide what
to invest you'll never see or you'll
seldom see a buy side equity research
analyst quoted in the Wall Street
Journal because that's not their job so
when you see an equity research analyst
mentioned in the journal is almost
always a cide equity
research so you're a cide equity
research analyst
congratulations you're given a
setor usually 15 or 20 companies you
told this these are the companies you're
going to track for the rest of your
life I would leave the job right away
but people say that's okay you know I'm
okay with that and for the what's your
job then to track these companies and to
put buy recommendations and sell
recommendations people think okay equ
research analyst value companies they
might value them they might be pric them
but my question is about buyers right if
you come up with a high number for your
company whether the valueable price it's
a buy if you come up with a low number
it's going to be a
sell you think there might be bias in
this
process
why because they want to like basically
like so you're saying a buy is much
better for you than a sell
right so whatever the you because you
have three different constituencies here
right you have your managing director
and the Investment Bank who might have
other business to do with the company
let you decide how that plays out when
you put a cell recommendation on a
company you have investors presumably a
waiting with baited bread for is he
putting a buy or a
sell and then there's the company itself
the the 15 or 20 companies say why would
I care about them because you're going
to live with them for the rest of your
life
right if you're an equity research let's
cut to the chase you're using the same
public information that I am you have no
differential advant
you have an Excel spreadsheet I have one
too use Python I can get python get
somebody to run I've never used python
in my valuation but I can do
that you do have a small Edge which is
what you talk to the management don't be
careful about going beyond that you just
talk because in the US the SEC is very
clear about this this notion of private
versus public but let's face it you're
waiting for these morsels of information
that are not quite in information but
they give you a little Edge that's your
Edge so you put a sell recommendation
what
happens you pick up the phone you call
the company and they all hang up on
you you know buy recommendations
outnumber cell recommendations 10 to1 it
used to be 25 to1 in the 1990s it's now
to1 you pick any company even the worst
company buys without out number
sells because there is bias in this
process you're saying I hate salside you
quit salside you go to work for
Fidelity and I'm a portfolio magic
ferity remember you work for me and I
tell you where I am I own 10 million
shares of invid and I'm deeply you know
troubled by this news that's come out of
our deep seek and I ask you to Value
inedia you're saying this is good I can
do an objective valuation remember you
want to also see when I give this news
to my portfolio manager will he be happy
or will he be upset right you see that's
that nothing to do with value it's got
everything to do with how he's going to
treat you afterwards or she's going to
treat you what is
the the the the the the answer analysis
I would like you to come back that would
make me happier what makes my life
easier as a portfolio
manager I don't have to sell it because
the minute I sell it I have that's
confirmation of going to my let's say I
bought at the start of this year I'm
selling it I'm writing off on $15 $16
per share so I'd like you to tell me
that it's okay you can hold
on conversely if I met a hedge fund I
sold short an Invidia and I say what do
you think about my decision I want you
to say
amazing I don't know whether you've ever
seen this movie A Few Good Men it's Jack
Nicholson movie I'd like you to watch it
especially towards the end of the movie
there's this quot scene where Jack
Nicholson is on this on the you know in
court and he's being questioned by I
don't know Tom Cruz you know whoever the
lawyer was in there and he is you know
basically there all these bad things
that Jack Nicholson has done that he's
covered up and you know the lawyer says
Mr I don't forget the name of the
general so and so could you please tell
us the truth and remember what what Jack
says you cannot handle the truth and
that in fact is something we have to
remember people claim they want to know
the true value for the company but I
need to have that Jack Nicholson me say
you cannot handle the truth right people
don't want to hear the truth they want
to have confirmation that whatever
they're thinking is okay and you can lie
about it dance around it but it is a
source of bias one
final question about
bias let's say you are a banker
and you're in the m&a
group so tell me again how this process
works I'm an acquiring company you're a
banker I come to you with a Target
company that I want to do a merger with
and ask you is this a good deal dumbest
question ever because asking a banker
whether a deal makes sense is like
asking a plastic surgeon whether there's
something wrong with your face right
what is he going to say this is a
terrible deal in which case what does he
get paid even if it's that's the truth
nothing you get 100 million if the deal
goes through you think again there might
be a wee bit of bias this is the most
bias process that I can think of m&a is
where valuation first principles go to
die because your end game is to justify
the unjustifiable the value of a Target
company is always $10 more than what you
chose to pay for it but for two weeks we
go through spreadsheets and changing
numbers and going to the managing
director and say that number looks too
low why don't you try this why don't we
just cut to the chase skip that two
weeks and just say value the target comp
it'll be much more honest much
cleaner and the target company has the
same incentive it wants to make the
there is nobody in that room who does
not want the deal to go through
right acquiring company sh managers
Target company managers acquiring
company Bankers you know what who's
missing in the room right whose money is
being thrown around so it's the
shareholders he saying what's the board
of directors doing what Boards of
directors do all over the world sleep on
the
job when was the last time a board
actually stepped in and say you guys are
paying too much don't do the deal it's
an exception it sometimes happens when
it happens you said really this can
happen so when you have merges again
bias feeds through and I let you think
about what happens in a hostile takeover
because one of the trickiest things in a
hostile takeover
is the two sides have different end
games right you're the banker for an
acquiring company you want to convince
your shareholders that this is a good
deal by showing them what that they're
paying less than something is worth once
it's out you give an ammunition to the
Target company Bankers because they go
to the and say look they said they're
paying less than it's worth that's not a
good deal for you how do you navigate
this you invent Bo it's like Synergy
that allows the magic to kind flow
through and say I can be right and not
be lying bias is
endemic to the m&a
process so it might sound like something
we should be that we should be talking
about more substantial things but the
truth is often when valuations go bad
it's because of one or more of those
biases so before I started today's um
slides of the intro evaluation I want to
say a few things about the project that
I mentioned last class I said form a
group I don't know whether I gave you
parameters on group numbers it can be
anywhere from 4: to 8 right for those of
you who are in my corporate finance
class the good news is this group
requires far less group interaction than
this you pick a company you pretty much
sail through you know there might be one
or two meetings towards the end to make
sure that you all got done that's really
what you're checking why because a
second year NBA which is what many of
you are you you're a little sick of each
other I would think in terms of group
work I don't want to hang out with those
people I'm getting ready to get out of
here I built that into the group
dynamics right so you're going to pick a
group and every one of you can pick
whatever company want unlike the
corporate finance project where you have
to pick a common theme there's no common
theme you can pick whatever company
Rings your Bell so if you are obsessed
with the Super Bowl and you can't let go
value draft kicks
he's saying why can't I value the Kansas
City Chiefs well if they give you access
to the financials by all means value the
Kansas City Chiefs and then you can
value the Taylor Swift Premium built
into the Kansas City Chiefs right that
would be a fascinating
exercise you pick any company can I can
you pick a private company Yes again if
you have access to the financials if you
have a family business you'd like valued
pick that each of you picks a company if
you have eight people in your group
you'll have eight companies okay there
is one constraint I will add and I'll
come back and talk about what that March
29th is here's the constraint I'm going
to
add at least one of the companies in
your group has to be a money losing
company with operating losses in the
most recent 12
months at least one of your companies
has to have high growth potential with
growth defined in revenues not earnings
because earnings growth can sometimes be
just because of accounting fixes cost
cutting this has to be your business
business is growing at least one of your
companies has to be a non us company and
I would like you if you can to value
that company in the local
currency so don't pick a Brazilian
company and value the ADR in dollars
because you no I want you to deal with a
valuation in r or pesos or rupia right
and at least one of your companies
Service Company I should take that
requirement out because pretty much
every company is now a Service
Company why do I put this constraint
because of all you do is pick nice
mature companies with a lot of history
you really don't need this class I want
you to wrestle with the pain of
difficult value companies of course you
could evade the system and here's what
you can do for a group of four pick nice
mature companies that all make money
then open your group to a fifth
person and tell them you can join our
group if you pick a money losing high
growth foreign company and there are a
few of those right this way you you pile
it all on that person but you got to
decide what you came into the class for
and if you want an easy ride pick
Proctor and Gamble it'll be easy to
Value boring as heck but easy to Value
if you want to challenge pick a company
that's young that's money losing because
that's where you you're you know you
will essentially get to deal with the
big questions in
valuation pick a company in the AI space
right now right everybody is saying I
don't know what's going to happen this
is exactly the time to do it right so
any questions on the group project yes
go ahead julan is obvious be public can
it be private like should it be public
because there we information necessarily
all I need is a value right so the
difference with the public versus
private what's the one thing you're
going to have with the public company
that actually makes your life a little
easier not the financial financials look
very
similar it's a fact that when you're
done you can at least tell whether
you're completely off the reservation
right by doing what by comparing the
market price you come up with the value
of share per share of 1,500 and the
market price is a $150 my guess is you
got a unit wrong somewhere right and
it's good to know whereas the private
company you're saying I don't know so it
is
actually sometimes interesting to think
about how much you rely on the market
price will you complain about the market
so I have no problem with you picking a
private company and IPO privately a
family group company so as long as you
can access the
financials so what I'm going to do for
the rest of this session spilling over
the next one is talk about the different
ways you can put a number on a company
when I first started teaching
valuation I made the mistake of assuming
that everybody else was as interested in
valuation as I
was huge mistake because it turn are
that most people don't believe in
valuation even most people who do
valuation for a living you see but they
do it every day they do it because it's
their job they do it to cover their rear
ends but if you caught them in an honest
moment ask why is NVIDIA trading at $125
per share you know what the answer is
because that's what the market thinks
it's
worth if that's what I felt about
valuation I couldn't teach this class so
I'm going to tell you why I do valuation
I do valuation to fight the LM in
me heard of lemmings Lemmings became
famous or inFAMOUS in the
1950s when either National Geographic of
Disney the parentage is a little unclear
created this documentary slovie where
they filmed this most amazing site
thousands of big ugly rat-like creatures
the way you could tell is if it were
Disney the rat-like creatures probably
have been cute looking because nothing
in a Disney movie can be not cute
gathered together on a cliff ran right
off the cliff into a into the ocean and
committed Collective suicide and ever
since one of the big questions is why do
they do
it were they off their medication what
is it that drives them I don't know the
answer but you can do some virtual
imagery you can see why the first leming
did it right he's going too fast he
couldn't stop off the cliff into the
ocean incident these guys can't swim so
that seems the deal of dead second guy
too close to first guy also off that
same cliff into the ocean also dead but
I'd like you to put yourself in the
shoes of the the very last leming I know
Lemmings don't wear shoes but kind of
hang in there with the analogy
anyway you're the very last leming in
your group you're running towards a
cliff you've seen your entire tribe
disappear off that Cliff right I would
think You' have second thoughts about
what you were just planning to
do your left brain right brain whatever
part of you is ration say stop stop and
then you hear this voice in the back of
your head you know what it's saying they
must know something that you don't
remember those seven words in investing
in
valuation I promise you you'll hear
those words you know when you hear those
words is when you value
inedia and you come up with $160 per
share and your rational sales go buy the
stock and you're looking at everybody
else selling they must know something
that I
don't I heard it last September I valued
inedia at $89 per share and that was
with a really big AI story with all the
stuff that I told you and this was after
the earnings report the stock had
dropped to
108 and they said it's I mean
everybody's talking about Bargain
Basement this is what you're going to
get and I now my first reaction was it
looks overvalued still but I heard that
voice they must know something that you
don't speaks in a monotone don't ask me
why and when you hear magical things
will tend to happen to your valuation
your growth rate will start to go up
your cash flows will start to get more
positive your discount rate will get
lower 89 become 95 97 you will notice
this phenomenon play out when you value
a company the market price will act like
a
magnet and you would move closer and
closer to because that's the most
comfortable place to
be they must know something that you
don't I divide the whole world of
investors into three groups of lemings
the first group I call proud lemings and
I'm leming I'm a leming and I'm proud to
be a l they call themselves momentum
investors but it's pretty much the same
thing right what do momentum investors
do they look for a crowd they join in
you're buying I'm buying you're selling
I'm selling why are you buying I really
don't care I can't pull off being a
proud leming it seems so mindless but
clearly some people are drawn to it the
second group I call Yogi Bear
lemings you heard of The Legend of Yogi
Bear lived in Yellowstone Park was
smarter than the average bear Yogi Bear
Lemmings think they're smarter than the
average leming you know what they want
to do they want to run with the rest of
the Lemmings to the very edge of the
cliff in the last moment you're away
admit it you're tempted you're saying
there's so many stupid people out there
I have an MBA from Stern I've taken
evaluation class I'm smarter than the
average leming I know where the cliff is
coming do
you I don't I would love to tell you
that I saw deep sea coming last weekend
I'd be
lying I would love to tell you I saw Co
take down the market and but I would
after the cliff comes all people look
back I knew that was coming but how come
you never mentioned
it I can't Bel you know be a proud
leming I can't I'm not smarter than the
average leming I can't tell where the
cliff is so if you ask me to describe
myself that's me right there a leming
with a life ver that's all I aspired to
be I mean you're a human being are you
going to get caught up in the mood at
the
moment absolutely
how the heck do you keep it out of the
so on Monday if you if you own invia
don't tell me that you didn't feel fear
don't tell me that you didn't feel that
urge to sell because you'd be lying you
know what valuation does for me it slows
the process down so I do own a piece of
the Invidia that I bought in
2018 I saw the pain that the weekend
inflicted on my portfolio I felt this
desire to join the crowd so I said look
let me try revaluing inedia that's going
to show up on T next Tuesday as
evaluation of the week but I don't do it
for you I do it for myself I do it to
slow the process down to allow my
rational side to mount an argument maybe
I'll join the rest of the crowd after
I've done it but valuation is about
slowing the process down so not just
looking at what other people are doing
and trying to do the same thing so with
that in place let's get rid of some
misconception of our valuation the first
one I already talked about bias this
notion that you're some kind of
scientist valueing companies gets fed
into because we sit in front of
computers we have all these numbers we
feed them in after a while we say I am
being objective I just work with the
numbers that's an absolute
lie every valuation is
biased for lots of different reasons
I'll give you a personal example I
valued Microsoft every year since 1986
the year of their IPO for the first 28
years of their existence I'll talk about
what happened in year
28 every time I valued Microsoft I found
it to be
overvalued $2 overvalue $4 strange right
one of the great great success stories
of the 20th century in terms of back
markets I wouldn't have touched it one
step away by 1999 Microsoft was the
largest market cap
company in the US and I said overvalued
every step of the way I could give you
access to every single Microsoft
valuation I've done the very first the
first two were in Lotus because Excel
hadn't showed up so you have to figure
out a way to open a Lotus spreadsheet
and you could dig through the
spreadsheets looking for Clues but you
be looking in the wrong
place you really want to know why I
found Microsoft to be
overvalued I would say go to the
elevators but these won't take you to
the right floor go down one floor hit
the elevator button I want to be
specific go up to the nth
floor and find your way to my office
it's tough to find it's like warrants of
rooms but eventually you'll get there
the the doors open walk in don't take
any of the steps just look around and
here's what you're going to see you're
going to see my MacBook Pro on a table
right next to it you will see my iPad
why because I like to watch movies while
I work on my MacBook
Pro I think I brought my uh my airpods
today see the little thing charging I
just capitulate ated and I have an Apple
Watch took me until 10 to get to it
Apple 10 no I finally capitulated
because I'm hoping that I don't need to
bring my phone down to log in because
every time I come in without my phone
I'm stuck it's like a dead terminal now
I'll see if that works it hasn't worked
so far so I might have to return the
watch but if you stay in my office and
look up towards the top shelf on the
very top shelf you'll see a Mac 128k
that was my very first Mac 1980
two it's actually it's a Mac that came
without a hard drive it came with a
floppy disc which you had to
flip and it actually
works I've been an Apple user since 1981
and to me Microsoft has always been the
Darth
Vader of technology for those of you
Star Wars fans let me be very specific
about which Darth Vader I'm talking
about I'm not talking episodes 1 2 three
Darth vad Skywalker cute kid I'm talking
456 guy dressed in black wears a mask
never takes a shower you I I don't know
what and I've always wondered does Darth
Vader take a shower it keeps me awake at
night but I have lots of bad thoughts
about Bill Gates and this is pre vaccine
nothing to do with vaccines they' come
bubbling up to the surface so when I sat
down to Value micro high growth or low
growth and I got to pick I said who buy
this rotten product low growth high risk
low risk one virus away from blowing up
high risk and by the time I made my
choices always over Val you know what I
learned I hate the company too
much T value so what happened after 28
years I started feeling sorry for
Microsoft you remember in
2013 Apple had left Microsoft in the
dust right it was a in terms of
corporate life cycle old company with
two big cash cars windows and office
kind of trudging its way towards death
it's tough to hate a company and you
feel sorry for it so you know what I did
I ended up buying Microsoft some of your
best investment decisions come from the
worst motives I didn't buy Microsoft
because I saw the cloud business taking
over even because I thought SATA nadela
was a great CEO I bought it because I
felt sorry for the
company but I've also given you a clue
of another company I've had really
difficult time valuing over the last 35
years right which is Apple I love the
company too much if you go to my blog I
valued Apple every year and if you look
at my first valuation of Apple I think
in 2010 I spend half the post telling
people don't trust
me that's all I can do I can't say I'm
going to set it to the side that would
be a lie to say I'm going to be
objective when you sit down each of you
is going to pick a company whether you
like it or not for the project right and
it's not going to be from a blank slate
it's going to be because have you picked
a company yet
anybody picked a company okay who do you
pick on on so on you familiar on shoes I
mean it's it's I've gone on the site
I've looked at the shoes and then I said
$180 I'm not paying but I'm I'm old so
but it's a company that's taken off that
essentially has broken into a business
where companies like Nike andery doesn't
been incredibly successful so why do you
pick
on and what what's the stuff you heard
about all M that people love it so
already you're walking in my guess is
already going so if you find your
company to be over well you you might
take a look everybody else loves the
company why am I and what's the stock
price and from from what so what has it
done in terms of change over
there so all those things will whether
you like it or not will affect when you
value the company what do you think
about the company right in fact what do
you told to to do when you first start
valuing is go find out as much as you
can read as much as you can about the
company talk to the management of the
company worst advice
ever in in my 40 Years of valuation I've
never once talked to the management of a
company two reasons one is what the heck
are you going to learn from them they're
PR people they're going to tell you a
nice story and second they're going to
put handcuffs on you right we gave you
the information we'd like to review your
valuation no I want to reserve the right
to say terrible things about management
and I don't want to give up that right
because the CE says I'll tell you
something secret about the
company and if you play golf with the
CEO of the company every
weekend I'm not interested in your
recommendation by or sell I have a
feeling that your golf game will have
much more to do with what you put as a
recommendation than what you find see
about the company and if you get paid to
do valuation you saw that play out in
that start of the class quiz then God
help you because bias will kind of I
mean he who pays the piper calls the
tune and if you get paid I can you could
it's not because you're a bad person I'm
not accusing you of being dishonest but
you will find ways to move your
valuation towards what the paying client
wants and you will convince yourself
you're doing it for all the right
reasons right and we'll talk about all
the ways you can do it but bias plays
out so I'll tell you a story to show how
deep bias is and how it can embed into
evation about 30 years ago company
called Lin
cable obviously it's a Broadcasting
Company a cable company and AT&T had
this option to buy 49% of lend cable at
an appraised value so that's where the
option was written the time for the
option to be exercised comes about AT&T
goes out and hires Morgan Stanley so you
guys are going to be Morgan Stanley you
work for AT&T and what's your job to
assess the value of the 49% so AT&T can
pay for that 49% so you work for the bar
Lin cable goes out and hires Leman
Brothers I'm sorry to do this to you but
think of yourselves as pre- bankrupt
Leman
brothers and your job is to assess the
value of the same 49% so I can sell it
same Financial same
company two Banks go to
work come back with two
valuations one is $105 per share the
other is
$155 per share I want you to guess which
side came back with 105 and W side came
back with 155
Gabriel and
why you work for the buyer right and but
if you look at the valuation standing
alone 200 Pages Equity risk premiums
betas cash flows cost of capital all the
kabuki dance stuff right which is you
know look look at me I'm doing
discounted cash flow valuation but this
could have been foretold you work for
the buyer you came in with a low number
you work for the seller you came with a
high number the difference was so large
they decide to call in a third
investment banker why why set for two
Fields instead when you can have three I
guess and you guys are going to be was
this paraly I'm going to say something
incredibly harsh about these guys but I
mean every word of it these guys could
value a $20 bill in a brown paper bag if
you put in front of them they'd invent
some multiple Enterprise Value to cash
in the bag next thing you know you'd be
paying $66 for
$20 but if you're was the parall you're
caught in the middle right you don't
want to piss off either side 105 155
where's the safest place for you to
be on middle 130 they came back with
$127 and I think
52 I'm going to let you in a little
secret in valuation if you ever asked to
Value something never ever come back
with a nice round
number don't tell me the Target price is
40 tell me
$38.8 it's amazing what that second
decimal point will do in terms of
intimidating people who might have
thought of asking you questions so I'm
not asking this guy got the second
decimal point nailed
down one of the great tragedies in
valuation is most valuation tragedy is
probably too strong a word but the
reality of valuation most valuations the
value gets at first the valuation
follows not supposed to be the way it is
but it is what it is bias what can you
do about bias absolutely nothing other
than be honest at least with yourself
you don't have to be honest with your
clients at least be honest with
yourself right in fact now I would
suggest you write your priors out right
after you pick a company you know I mean
by writing your prior out so I picked a
company I think I'm going to find it
undervalue because I really write it out
put it in know because that's a way you
kind of remind yourself you're walking
in with these
biases in fact in statistics there's a
branch of Statistics called beian
statistics have you heard ban statistics
so in ban statistics what do we do can
you describe what what you're doing
basan
statistics let's say you're doing
research on a vaccine
right and you're trying to see if the
vaccine Works in ban statistics before
you show me your research or even do
your research you're supposed to tell me
before I even look at this vaccine my
belief is this vaccine will
work because we all start with some some
priors right that's called a prior and
then you show me what you found let's
say you find that vaccines do work
doesn't mean I'm going to throw your
research out but I'm going to discount
it because your prior and what's called
your posteriors match up but let's say
you go and saying I don't think this
vaccine will work and you're being
honest about your prior and you find the
vaccine works that's a pretty that
research is think of how much stuff
passes by as research findings that you
read about in the news and then you ask
yourself can I trust this
research part of the reason you feel
wary is you know that people bring in
agendas and biases into this process
I've done enough research there's reason
I don't do academic research anymore
it's
pointless because the end game is often
people academics L we objective no
there's no such thing as objective if
you have a strong enough preconception
it's going to find its
way second stop if I do good valuation
I'm going to get the right answer
Leon when does that get
started when does that feeling of if I
do things right I get the right answer
when does
that you start in first grade like all
of us right first grade teacher comes up
puts a sheet of paper in front of you 3
plus two you get five congratulations
you got the right answer you get any
other answer what are you told you got
the wrong answer start on your fingers
again right just get the if you got the
wrong answer you must have done
something wrong that get drummed into
you over and over and God help you if
you become if you go on to maybe how
many of you recovering
engineers then you get five more years
if you do the right if you get the if
you you do things right you get the
right answer if you got the wrong answer
you must have done something
wrong and then you end up in this class
and you bring that same lesson with you
you say if I do things right I'll get
the right valuation if I get the wrong
valuation I must have done something
wrong this is a recipe for beating
yourself
up because you're going to be wrong not
because you didn't do the right stuff or
get the inputs right it's because
there's a whole world out there that's
not in your control so if you valued in
viia last Friday it's unfair of me to
come in and say how come you didn't see
this deep seek thing
coming the truth is there are no right
answers the problem with fair value
accounting is they think the endgame
evaluation is
precision that's why they write all
these rules their their their
description of a good valuation process
gives you the same
answer over and over again so 100 people
tried and the word they should be really
focusing on is accuracy can you be
accurate and imprecise absolutely if
you're Ving a young company accuracy
basically means you're trying to get
close to the the right
answer precise means you get the same
wrong answer over and over again how is
that a great
practice so the truth is when you value
company your answers are going to be
imprecise inaccurate and it's not your
fault but what if you have two companies
with v wildly different characteristics
let's go back to March of 2019 I was
teaching this class down in Paulson and
it was a it was a while week for IPOs a
lot of IPOs coming out and that week two
companies went public high-profile
companies the first was a company called
lft Lyft actually predated Uber is the
first right sharing company in the world
to go public so you guys are going to
Value left the other company later in
the week that went public is a company
called Levi stra you think Levi St
didn't go public to 2019 they used to
they've been around 150 years they used
to be public in the last century were
taking private and they were going back
public so you guys are going to Value
Levi St so I'm going to ask you a very
easy question I think which of these two
companies do you think I can value more
accurately and what is it about Levi
that makes it easy to Value they have a
long history you know exactly how they
make money if you're confused and you're
wearing jeans just turn and look at the
you know back of your jeans in a miror
there it is like the 501 is still
carrying the company and what is it that
makes lift difficult the
value these guys can't figure out how to
make money they know how to scale up
none of them so Business Without a
business model you how did it get so big
blame VCS who kept feeding cap saying
don't worry about business models just
have more Riders more cities they took
it to heart much more difficult to Value
because the history is tumultuous to put
it mildly you have no idea whether the
company can ever figure it out and if I
judge valuations based on which one is
more accurate Levi Strauss will always
get an A and Lyft will always get a c
and if I did that guess what what
everybody's going to
Value craft HS and Levi stra over and
over again but that's doesn't make sense
and here's why it's true Levi stra is
easier to Value than left but if I'm
going to ask you a followup
question where is the payoff to doing
valuation greater what's the payoff to
doing valuation you find a market
mistake
right where do you think the pay off to
doing valuation is
Greater leas St is easy to Value but
it's easy to value for everybody in fact
I don't even think you need a body right
you could probably get Chachi PT please
value Levi my guess is the answer will
be pretty close to what you got because
Chachi PT can be trained look at history
do the
extrapolation
conversely most people will not even try
to Value left because they give up too
much uncertainty you know how often when
I talk to VCS they give me that because
most vs have never ever ever valued a
company they're price companies hundreds
of them they price run subscribers users
all kinds of neat stuff but they don't
they can't and you ask them why don't
you value companies the answer is
there's too much
uncertainty if any of you haven't picked
a company and you're saying what should
I pick go where it's
darkest sounds like a ominous threat
find a nice Ukrainian Mining Company
need to value good luck with finding a
nice Ukrainian mining company but you
never again complain about risk and
uncertainty after your valid the
Ukrainian Mining Company
right because that's where Market
mistakes greatest if you've never owned
Invidia this is the time to Value inv
say Let me let things settle down and we
no no this is it this is when
uncertainty is greatest this is the time
to Target companies buyas
uncertainty and the third component here
is complexity yes I don't say a name
plate sorry I lost my name that one so
when you look at situations that are
uncertain and let's say it's not hugely
uncertain right there are maybe 15
possible scenarios that to no let's face
the world lives in continuous space the
scenario thing already is going to get
you into trouble right so we do that for
convenience scenarios work work better
with regulatory risk but let's suppose
the world is simple in the so so the
number of scenarios tells me how much
uncertainty you face or the the
differences between the scenarios just
in any typical situation like this does
it make sense to look at like the
expected value of it's always the end
game right the question is how do you
come up with the expectations you build
them as an expected cash flow do you
let's say you do 15 scenarios you come
up with 15 values to make this into an
expected value what what's the last
piece of the puzzle
probabil in theory that's what we're
supposed to be doing in valuation in
practice we very quickly realize that
that's not going to get first in most
companies there are no 15 scenarios
right I'll give an example of a case
where I did use scenarios and I valued
easy jet in 2019 why are you scenarios
because it was facing this moment where
you didn't know where brexit would go
right you know it could it could fall
apart good brexit easy bre so I actually
valued it three because it is a very
different End Game Reserve scenarios for
times when you're looking at regulatory
changes that make your company more or
less valuable but we'll talk about other
tools better tools for dealing with
uncertainty this brings me to the third
misconception about valuation if I make
my model
bigger it's going to get
better most deadly trap to fall
into I going to give away my agent you
know since you can look it up in
Wikipedia you can it's not I'm not
giving away some state
secret by telling you what I used on my
first valuation 1981 I I I picked a
company to
Value I don't even remember the name of
the company but you know what I had to
do to get the annual reports I had to
write to the company with a fountain
pen write to the investment could you
please send me an annual report I sent
it by mail snail mail
two weeks later to give the company
credit by snail mail I get an annual
report in the mail I'm deliriously
joyful I open up the annual report and
here are the things I had in front of me
I had a ledger
sheet you know what a ledger sheet looks
like just a blank sheet of paper with
lines already pre-drawn huge Innovation
from my perspective because I always got
the Rines crook crooked so I The Columns
lines all drawn nothing on the
sheet I had a calculator not a slide
rule I'm not that old but I had a cal on
the
side and a pencil I learned very early
in my valuation life do not write things
that you can't
erase cuz you will have to erase things
and I start filling out the valuation
when you do a valuation with a ledger
sheet a pencil and a calculator how many
line items do you think there will be in
evaluation as few as you can get away
with right because every single cell has
to be hand calcul Cal at you add an
extra line item that's 10 more cells
you're calculating each
one valuations were parsimonious because
you had no
choice I told you I'm planning to
revisit my Invidia evaluation this week
you know where I'm going to go I'm going
to go to Capital IQ I'm going to send
you the specifics of how you can get
it's a amazing
database in about one minute I can
download every single financial data
item in Nvidia going back through its
entire life 26 years I can download take
one minute I have an entire spreadsheet
while I'm there in an extra two minutes
I can download the financials for every
Semiconductor Company in the world in 3
minutes I have all this data I no longer
use a leder sheet a pencil and a
calculator have an Excel spreadsheet and
you know some some things pre-built into
it so I can put the numbers in the
spreadsheet and if I want to add a line
item in a spreadsheet sometimes it's so
smart I don't even have to copy and
paste I do it it remembers the equation
of the previous one it it up this is
amazing right say that took well let me
add another line item and you can see
where this ends up right at the end you
end up with what I call banking
valuations have you ever seen banking
valuations usually there'll be 10
worksheets 500 line items all connected
in some mysterious Way by whom you have
no idea it was built by somebody
somewhere you have to call it when
something goes wrong with your
reinvestment you're
completely it's easy to build complex
models and people say well I'm doing it
because I want my models to be more
realistic but remember you want your
models to be work better getting value
two things happen with these models one
is I what I you know they become black
boxes you feed numbers in something you
know how you can tell is when an analyst
writes a valuation report and in the
valuation report they say the model
value the company
at really what it do sneak into your
office office in the middle of the night
value the company leave it on your desk
but saying don't blame me there's this
complex model and I feed numbers in I
work for the model not the other way
around get black boxes the second is
what I call input
fatigue you know what that is usually
hits you at Saturday night at 11:00
you're still at your desk at Investment
Bank you've been working all
week and your managing director comes
through as an annual report on your desk
physical report say I want this company
valued first thing tomorrow
morning it says trial by fire he wants
to see how much you really want this job
you think briefly about your option to
abandon very satisfying when you
exercise it usually takes a form of
picking up the annual report throwing in
your managing D you do it yourself
that's a deeply satisfying moment as it
leave but then deeply dissatisfying
things
follow including how the heck are you
going to pay a rent so you think briefly
about that moment then he say okay I'll
value the company and with the inhouse
valuation
model and you start entering numbers
hundreds and hundreds of
inputs you get to the 75th input it says
what was the working capital 5 years ago
part of you wants to get out of the
chair go look it up but it's too tired
the other part says just make up a
number just make up a random number it's
amazing how the random numbers roll lot
and the scary thing is when the output
comes out it's so complex that the
random numers swim with the numbers you
spend hours thinking about it nobody has
any
idea complexity is something that
technology and data allowed and we've
fallen into the trap in fact I'll send
you a link to a session that I did
called the Bermuda Triangle of valuation
because somebody asked me can you come
in and talk about valuation how to do it
right they thought I was going to come
in and talk about betas and cost to
Capital and you know how to get cash
flows right that's not why valuations
fall apart it's because of the three
things we talked about bias complexity
and
uncertainty the reason I use the word
Bermuda Triangle is as mythical area in
the Atlantic where supposedly ships and
planes go to disappear the Bermuda
Triangle is where Good Sense
disappears you're going to be fighting
those battles as you value companies
okay so it's better to be open about
bias and complexity uncertainty and make
your own compromises
right so I'm going to set the table for
what this class about there are three
ways you can put a number on a company
the first is intrinsic valuation what is
intrinsic valuation you value an asset a
company a business based on its cash
flows growth and risk now you can dress
it up with a discounted cash flow
valuation but intrinsic valuation
predates discounted cash flow valuation
discounted cash flow valuation as we
know it is about
perhaps 85 years old I think the very
first mention was a 1937 book by John
Williams but that Venetian glass maker
in the 15th century sold his business
based on cash flows growth and risk
trust me that's that's what people have
already
get so we're going to start with
intrinsic valuation then we're going to
move on to another way you can attach a
number to a company which is your price
and we talked about this in terms of the
theme what's different is demand and
Supply what are other people pay so
we're going to do that's a second there
is a third subset where there are some
assets whose cash flows are contingent
or some businesses where the cash flows
are contingent on something happening
again I briefly mentioned this I think
in the first class but if you're a young
farmer company with a drug working its
way through the pipeline there is a
contingency if it gets approved you
could be a a billion doll company if not
you're worth nothing that's the special
place where real options inhabit we'll
come and talk about real options and how
it's a very limited space so don't get
crazy about applying real options
everywhere but there are only three ways
you can put a I won't already dispell
this mythology that there are hundreds
of ways you can value companies there
only
three within each you can make choices
but are you doing an intrinsic valuation
of pricing or you talking about a real
option so we're going to start this
class off and spend a big chunk of it
talking about intrinsic valuation but
before I go there
during my office hours and I do have
office hours drop by when you get a
chance somebody from my undergraduate
valuation class came in and said do you
think markets are
perfect I said can we rephrase that a
little bit perfect is such a strong word
I said do you mean do you think markets
do
you your watch will talk to my watch so
I I completely because I got tired of it
talking back to me I was working this
morning it said stand up I said what
he says you've been sitting too long how
would you know he maybe I'm doing
exercises while I'm sitting down so but
the no I said do you mean is the
question are markets efficient she said
yeah that's the question I'm asking I
said if I believe markets were efficient
would I be teaching this class CU in an
efficient market what's the value inv
right now the market price is the best
estimate value not a bad
assumption right
but the minute you open up the Prof I'm
going to Value companies I'm going to
price them whether you like it or not
you implicitly telling me that markets
make mistakes that you can find the
mistakes with your pricing metric p
ratio Price to Book or with your
discounted cash flow models and is there
something else you're also telling me to
finish the story is finding a market
mistake going to make you
money no not unless the market SC it
corrects its mistakes don't forget that
last piece you can find a market mistake
and go
bankrupt what's your saying the market
can stay irrational longer than you can
stay
solvent right it's a good thing to
remember right you think you're right
you're rational you all the market can
do crazy stuff so I'm going to argue
that these three approaches make
different assumptions about Market
mistakes and as you think about these
three approaches what I also want you to
think about as an endgame from this
class is which one do I want to put my
trust in as an investor I'm not going to
pre-sell you and say you have to do
intrinsic valuation you have to make
your choices and one of the things that
are going to drive those choices is what
kind of mistakes do you think markets
make so let's start with discounted cash
flow valuation what is it it's the very
first class we all get in finance right
foundation's class probably started with
this which is the value of an asset is
the present value of the expected cash
flows the old days we used to make you
buy a financial calculator you know why
to teach you the meaning of a sun
cost cuz you then came to a first
finance class and you didn't like it and
you wanted to drop it you can but
there's a sun cost the bookstore won't
take your calculator back but used to
wear out that button on your financial
calculator the PV button there were all
these virgin buttons you never touch
have you noticed in the calculator E2 XL
what the heck is all of that stuff you
don't touch the PV but because 80% of
Finance is a present value problem
intrinsic valuation there an extension
of that very very core basic concept
philosophically what are you trying to
do you're trying to estimate the
intrinsic
value of something and I have some bad
news you'll never get to see it it's
like a little bit like the search for
the Holy Grail how long have people been
searching Thousand Years 1200 years has
anybody found it I think Indiana Jones
in the first movie came really close but
even and he didn't get it intrinsic
valuation is very much like the search
for the holy gra you keep looking and
you keep looking and you never find it
but you keep the
faith and if you break down discounted
cash flow models down no matter how
complicated they are here's what you'll
see you see a life for the asset
expected cash flows over that life and a
discount rate that reflects the
riskiness of the cash
flows are you assuming you make Market M
markets make mistakes when you do
absolutely you're also assuming you can
find those mistakes with your
DCFS and then you're also assuming that
the market will correct mistakes the DCF
you saying how do I make that happen you
could go on social media and post invid
is undervalued inv video is undervalued
inv video is under maybe you have
millions of followers maybe you can get
Mr Beast to post for you I always what
100 what is he 100 million followers on
YouTube maybe you can do a YouTube video
Nvidia is under
value but the reality is most of us
don't control the
process say how do I ensure Corrections
happen you don't that's why I use the
word
Fai I do have two pieces of good news
one is the longer your time Horizon the
greater the chance assuming you were
right in the first place that the price
will adjust value already I've given you
one of the things that should determine
whether you should believe in intrinsic
valuation or pricing
ask portfolio man what the typical time
Horizon is they say
longterm you know why because that's
what you're supposed to say so ask them
a different question how often do your
clients come and bug you about what the
portfolio is in every 3 months it's okay
that's your time
Aris they say should I do intrinsic
valuations say don't waste your time do
pricing not because you can't get value
right but in three months who knows what
the market will do the longer your time
Horizon the greater the chance Market
will correct its
mistakes so let's think about the
advantages of discounted cash flow
valuation intrinsic valuation the
disadvantages and who might be the best
kinds of people to use intrinsic
valuation because intrinsic valuation
requires that you estimate cash flows
and growth it requires that you
understand the business you cannot value
Cisco if you think it makes vegetable
oil
[Music]
right because you can know everything
about cash flows growth and risk you
cannot value Invidia if you can't at
least get a sense of this AR market and
where it's
going it requires you to understand the
business the company the management and
that's a lot of work
right and it exposes you why because you
make an assumption what per of the time
are you going to be wrong 100% and
people going to pick on you I got your
cost you have to get used to that that's
okay but it is in line with I mean
people who claim to be Buffett followers
one of the things that he said that I
truly buy into is he said I don't buy
shares in a company I buy a piece of a
business and if that's your ethos then
you should be using intrinsic
valuation so those the advant what are
the disadvantages it's going to require
a lot more work I can price the company
in three
minutes because I really don't even know
need to know what you do I find other
companies like it look at what investors
are doing attach a multiple I'm done
discounted cash flow valuation does take
time and more inputs I'm going to later
on we do pricing I'm going to argue that
embedded in pricing are assumptions
about cash flows growth and risk but you
don't have to make them explicit which
means you can never be critiqued for
getting them
wrong and when you do an intrinsic
valuation you can find a company to be
undervalued overvalued but let's say
you're an equity research analy you
decide to do discounted cash flow
valuation you value the 15 companies in
your sector is it possible that all 15
could come out as overv
value can happen then what should you do
put out s recommendation all 50 you know
how long you last as an equity research
analyst if you did that you're going to
be fired your job might require you to
have a balance you're an equity
portfolio imagine Fidelity can you
imagine going up to your boss and saying
you know what I think all stocks are
overvalued I'm going to pull all the
money in the fund out and hold it in
cash
cash you should be fired because that's
not your job your job is to be fully
invested in equities the promet
discounted CRA valuation is it doesn't
lend itself to that
Nuance so let's think about the kinds of
people for whom intrinsic valuation
works the best first philosophically you
got to think about businesses investing
in businesses not buying
shares second if you think about where
this can be applied it can be applied
only on investments that generate cash
flows so if you ask me what the value of
something is that doesn't generate cash
flows I'm going to tell you it can't be
valued you're going to be deeply
disappointed in me but I'm just
reflecting the
truth so what's uh an investment you see
out there always in the news that people
keep asking is it undervalued overvalued
where you could use
this Bitcoin right 100,000 you know how
many times I keep getting asked is
Bitcoin
undervalued you can't value Bitcoin not
because it's crypto but because it's a
currency so I ask me can you value the
dollar I can price the dollar against
other currencies called an exchange rate
the Bitcoin price against the dollar is
an exchange I can price it I can't value
can you value Picasso of course
not I can price it it's a collectible
against other
picassos so stay in your lane with
intrinsic valuation you can use it and
for the kinds of investors you thinking
about first it's nice to have a long
time
Horizon but remember you don't often
control it if you're managing other
people's
money so you're a portfolio manager I
started an advantage over a portfolio
manager because a portfolio manager has
a client to answer to but if you're
managing your own money you control your
time Horizon the only person I have to
answer to is my
spouse and I've turned off the statement
so it's paperless now at any given point
she has no idea we've investing in Ria
so she hasn't asked me any questions
this week
yet but I'm willing to hold as long as I
need
to so you have a long time Arizon you
know later on this class we're going to
talk about the most famous value
investor of all time who talking Buffett
had what he brought to the table that
allowed I mean he didn't use private
information he wasn't using Insider
information so what was his
biggest Edge in this investing game what
do you think he brought to the table the
other
inv sorry about
this TK trying to sell me
something but know why does he have a
long time why doesn't he have clients
who come back and bug him just like
portfolio managers
do who what what money is he investing
insure if let's face it bura way is a
really good insurance company in Geico
with a closed and mutual fund every
insurance compan is like that but most
insurance companies a Clos in mutual
fund is not a value created it's run by
an average investor if you're lucky or a
below average one if you're not buire
hatway is an insurance company with the
closed in fund run by the most famous
value investor of all time and when you
invest insurance company capital what
drives No your time Horizon the
Actuarial tables
right and the good thing about Actuarial
tables is they don't panic on you in
2008 in November of 2008 I remember in
one week in that first week of November
Warren Buffett took positions in Bank of
America and Goldman
Sachs this was in the midst of one of
the worst financial crisis of all time
and financial service companies were
right at the heart of it and there a lot
of portfolio managers said look you know
I think Goldman Sachs will make it
through it's going to be one of the
survivors here you know but they
couldn't take a position because they
couldn't go to their clients say I just
bought Goldman Sachs that have been
fired on but Warren Buffett said look
I'm investing Actuarial money I'll take
it it's an ad it's an the biggest
Advantage you can have as an
investor is to be able to sell liquidity
which is a nice way of saying I have a
long time rise in the of a crisis I can
buy things long time Horizon is nice
would it be nice if you could also be a
catalyst to make that correction happen
you know what I mean by that you buy
something
undervalued remind me again how car I
can runs his fun I'm not talking about
the Hindenburg view of K I can but the
preh Hindenberg view what does he do he
takes a position in a company
right then does he stay really quiet
now he gets as loud as he can you see
him everywhere and what's he saying the
stock is undervalued the stock is but
it's called I can so other people join
in one things that activist investors
like Bill Amman and car I can and Elliot
have going for them is they can act as
their own catalysts which is they can
trigger that correction which makes the
process a little more
controllable and finally and this is I
think the psychological issue let's face
an intrinsic valuation you're often
going to be going against the
crowd everybody around you is going to
tell you you're
crazy and if when you are in school you
are easily swayed by pure groups you
will not be a good candidate for
intrinsic
valuation but if in school you were that
obnoxious kid who did the opposite of
what everybody else was doing this is
your chance reel in that bad
quality the nature of intrinsic
valuation is you're more likely to be a
contrarian buying things when other
people are selling you're saying in
theory I'm a contrarian in practice it's
really difficult to be a
contrarian because that buying Nidia on
Monday morning and think about how
much that requires you to go against
what everybody else is
doing so we'll we'll we'll pause there
when we get back on Wednesday we're
going to talk about pricing and real
options very quickly and we're going to
start in the first packet so if you
haven't downloaded the first packet
please do so it's a really big packet so
it'll take a while to download have some
patience